dans un petit peu plus d'un mois ouvrira
le premier grand festival de france de
l'année civile on parle du printemps de
bourges bien évidemment et en
particulier du festival off avec son
directeur
boris veut d'elle en direct de de
bourges merci d'être avec nous
alors est ce que l'on peut déjà rappeler
en quoi consiste le festival off alors
bonjour benoît le festival off c'est le
printemps dans la ville cette année en
fait on essaie un petit peu de tout
construire autour de ceux de ce nom qui
existait déjà pour les berruyers les
festivals et qui va ce festival depuis
longtemps maintenant
c'était initialement tout ce qui se
passait dans les bars et dans les
restaurants mais depuis quelques années
on construit beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de nouvelles choses en fait on propose
plein de choses que ce soit des
expositions des conférences plein de
concerts de 300 concerts gratuits dans
toute la ville et l'idée c'était de tout
mettre sous la même bannière c'est le
printemps dans la ville et le printemps
de bourges et le printemps de bourges
printemps dans la vie et c'est qu'il
sait tout ce qui est en accès libre
donc tout ce qui est gratuit donc c'est
vraiment une offre culturelle à
destination des curieux et puis surtout
à destination des familles tout
simplement ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
ils veulent pas jeter places de concert
y a pas d'eau chaude inter à bourges
pendant le printemps de bourges et
bourhis vedel précisément 14 restaurants
dix sept bars vont jouer le jeu il y
aura 250 concerts notamment place
séraucourt hôtel cujas un petit festival
finalement dans grands festivals c'est
même un grand festival dans l'autre
grand festival effectivement que ce soit
on construit beaucoup de choses avec les
expositions notamment une exposition
autour des femmes c'est la grande
thématique l'exclamation du printemps de
bourges cette année tout ce qui est
l'expression féminine à travers la
musique parce qu'on aime bien construire
à bourges ce reflet entre musique et
société on a un festival qui est dans la
ville on n'est pas un festival dans un
champ ou ailleurs on est vraiment dans
la vie donc pour nous c'est intéressant
de rappeler effectivement festivaliers
et à tous ceux qui viennent à bourges
que la culture se construit dans la
ville et on devrait enfin vraiment faire
un festival pour tout le monde ait
oublié personne
vous le disiez notamment pour pour les
familles c'est un festival off plus
accessible pour les familles surtout au
niveau financier je suppose tout à fait
tout est gratuit on peut vraiment
devenir printemps de bourges sans
nécessairement avoir acheté une place de
concert pour 1
nombreux spectacles qui sont dans les
salles de bourges dans la ville c'est
quatre scènes officielles qui sont
programmés par le printemps de bourges
mais aussi voilà tous les bars les
restaurants qui se prennent au jeu
mais ce sont aussi des magasins sont
aussi les musées de la vie c'est la
cathédrale c'est le palais jacques coeur
il ya vraiment des choses à faire
partout dans toute la ville et
gratuitement et l'idée c'est que la
ville et la direction du printemps
travail pour faire de bourges finalement
une ville encore plus dynamique
fin avril ce sera du 24 au 29 avril
cette année tout à fait ça sera cette
année l'idée voilà ni le printemps de
bourges
n'oubliez pas de prendre votre badge
bonjour et prier pour vous benoît je
vous offrirai avec plaisir et l'idée
c'est effectivement de reverser tous les
fonds à la fondation abbé-pierre cette
année ce contre le mal logement et ça
sera donc l'association partenaire du
printemps de bourges et du printemps
dans la ville merci beaucoup feu laboris
venelles d'avoir été en direct avec nous
de bourges le printemps de bourges du 24
au 29 avril prochain merci beaucoup